aujourd'hui j'ai envie de parler de
handicap trop souvent passés sous
silence et dont notre canton s'est
montré précurseur dans la prise en
charge au côté du conseil départemental
l'Institut les tournesols à Sainte-Marie
au mine accueille dans ses nombreuses
structure des personnes en situation de
handicap qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement thérapeutique médicalisé
mais aussi des adultes en situation de
handicap et qui vont dans ces structures
là retrouver projet professionnel le
projet que j'ai choisi d'évoquer est
celui d'un site de prise en charge et
d'accueil des enfants et adolescents en
situation de handicap avec un
accompagnement thérapeutique spécifique
une pédagogie innovante et étroitement
ancrée dans le contact avec la nature et
l'expression artistique qu'elle soit
musicale théâtral ou plutôt plastique un
projet humain riche et Pr prux dans un
site exceptionnel on témoigne derrière
moi
l'école qui est entourée d'un jardin
potager directement cultivé en
biodynamie par les jeunes sous la
conduite de leurs éducateurs une belle
initiative qui mérite d'être souligné
aujourd'hui nous sommes ici devant le
collège George Martelot
d'orbet la construction la rénovation
l'entretien des collèges est une
compétence importante du conseil
départemental et le collège d'orbet a
été entièrement rénové il y a 2 ans
d'importants travaux ont été entrepris
sur la structure d'origine qui date de
1976 pour améliorer les performances
énergétiques mais aussi permettre son
accessibilité aux personnes à mobilité
réduite et offrir des espaces de travail
fonctionnels et adaptés aux pratiques
pédagogiques actuelles tout en ménageant
des espaces de travail plus euh réservés
au collégiens plus spécifiques pour les
collégiens comme le
foyer le collège d'orbet propose un
cursus d'enseignement bilingue mais
également une section sportive football
il est niché au cœur du pays Velge et
c'est en fait le plus haut collège de
l'Académie de Strasbourg et sa situation
en montagne non loin de la station de
ski du Lac Blanc lui permet également de
proposer au collégiens une section
sportive ski alors le Conseil
départemental entre 2002 et 2013 a mené
une politique montagne vicieuse et et
donc d'importants investissements ont
été
entrepris et ont permis de moderniser
les équipements de ce site de loisirs
été hiver et les équipements actuels de
la station de ski du Lac Blanc permett
au collégiens d'avoir un enseignement
spécifique en ski dans trois disciplines
le ski alpin le ski Nordic et le
snowboard depuis maintenant presque 20
ans grâce à un partenariat efficace
entre l'éducation nationale les
partenaires et les clubs locaux et je
crois que c'est une belle réussite qui
mérite d'être soulignée parce qu'elle se
fait au profit de nos collégiens je vous
invite à profiter d'un magnifique
panorama sur le Val d'Argent si j'ai
choisi de m'y arrêter c'est pour mettre
en valeur la richesse paysagère de notre
canton et l'importance des actions
menées par le Conseil départemental du
Hain dans le domaine de l'environnement
nous sommes en 2016 et le département du
Ain fait les 16 ans de ces gerplans un
gerplan c'est tout simplement un outil
d'aménagement des territoires pour
concilier les différents usages de
l'espace les activités agricoles
l'expansion de l'urbanisation mais aussi
la protection du patrimoine des espaces
naturels et humides et des
ressources